E.T. is one of the most critically beloved
and commercially successful films of all time.
With a lifetime worldwide box office of almost
$800 million, E.T. could probably still get
a sequel greenlit in seconds.
So why didn't Universal phone home to see
if they could get the little guy back for
a second adventure?
Here's why E.T. II: Nocturnal Fears never
happened.
Stuck at the starting line
E.T. screenwriter Melissa Mathison struck
up a creative relationship with director Steven
Spielberg while she was dating Harrison Ford
during filming for Raiders of the Lost Ark.
According to producer Kathleen Kennedy, Spielberg
was already a fan of her work on The Black
Stallion, and after they hit it off, Mathison
got the gig for E.T.
Over $700 million in box office returns later,
Spielberg wanted to see if she could make
lighting strike twice with a follow-up.
But the outline they sketched together was
never anything more than a tentative stab
at a sequel.
A writer and director sitting down to bang
out a nine-page treatment for an idea isn't
anywhere close to pre-production.
It got very dark
If E.T. 2 had followed the treatment written
by Spielberg and Mathison, the film would
have shown a group of aliens descending to
Earth in response to the distress call from
"Zrek," which turns out to be E.T.'s real
name.
Cool, more little E.T.s, right?
Not really.
These "albino mutations," would have red eyes
and razor sharp teeth, kinda like E.T.'s evil
neighbors or second-cousins or something.
They spend some time in the woods, mutilating
cattle and capturing animals in "light cages"
before Elliot, Gertie, and their friends show
up mistakenly thinking E.T. is back.
The kids are interrogated and Elliot is tortured
into unconsciousness while crying for E.T.
to save him.
Sounds like the perfect follow-up to a family-friendly
classic, huh?
The treatment has a happy ending, and it's
obviously just a small part of a longer, more
detailed story.
But still, turning E.T. even partially into
a horror movie seems like a stretch.
Not to mention the Hershey Company would probably
not be too thrilled to see Reese's Pieces
being associated with sadistic intergalactic
torturers.
"Oh, Reeses Pieces"
Spielberg's first sequel
Steven Spielberg famously hated the idea of
sequels for a long time, having declined Universal's
request for another Jaws film for years...before
they finally made one anyway without him.
His treatment for E.T. II: Nocturnal Fears
was supposedly drafted just days after the
original arrived in theaters, and might have
been little more than the byproduct of that
initial excitement.
Spielberg eventually came around to the idea
of sequels when he filmed Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom three years later.
But it should be pointed out that he's only
ever done four sequels throughout his career,
and they've been for two of the biggest movie
franchises of all time — Indiana Jones and
Jurassic Park.
This is a guy who chooses his projects wisely,
and the story of E.T.'s sadistic relatives
clearly didn't fit into his artistic vision.
One and done
E.T. is a timeless classic — and a fully
realized story with likeable characters, great
visual effects, and above all, a feel-good
resolution about friendship and love that
audiences of all kinds can appreciate.
Spielberg said it himself in an interview
with Empire Magazine in 2009:
"E.T. is a closed story.
It had a beginning, middle, and a definite
ending, and we had nowhere to take it except
to go home with him.
Nor did I want to bring him back to Earth
for a second time."
E.T isn't an action hero who's only just shown
us the beginning of what he can do.
Making an E.T. sequel would have been akin
to making It's A Wonderful Life 2...which
also almost happened.
Thanks, Hollywood.
Spielberg pulled the plug
In a speech to the American Film Institute,
Spielberg said,
"I think a sequel to E.T. would do nothing
but rob the original of its virginity.
People only remember the latest episode, while
the pilot tarnishes."
...which is quite a reverential way to talk
about a movie featuring a cross-dressing,
candy-binging alien who communicates through
a Speak & Spell.
But it also begs the question: When did he
change his mind?
And why didn't he give George Lucas this memo
decades ago?
"I'll try spinning, that's a good trick."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know if you'd
still like to see a sequel to E.T...